honestly I like a drink as much the next
manner unless the next man is Mel Gibson
and there's Charles Woodson how about
that now what a season he had he became
the first defensive player to win the
Heisman Trophy congratulations Charles
that is something that no one can ever
take away from you unless you kill your
wife and a waiter in which case
the teacher base could not be here
tonight because he is no longer
technically in show business talking of
all you perverts it was a big year it
was a big year for pedophile movies
surviving our Kelly leaving Neverland to
Pope's shout out shout out I don't care
I don't care
yeah the Nuggets are having a bad year
this year man matter of fact they're
making a film about the team they're a
pretty catchy title it's black men can't
jump either Meryl Streep is not here
tonight she has the flu and I hear she's
amazing in it I've known that for a long
time now you know what I've known Matt
so long when I first met Matt I was the
fat one you could binge watch the entire
first season of after life instead of
watching this show that that's a show
about a man who wants to kill himself
because his wife dies of cancer and it's
still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way
so in the end he obviously didn't kill
himself just like Jeffrey Epstein shut
up I know he's your friend but I don't
care
it was a great year for film women in
film Kathryn Bigelow nominated tonight I
haven't really been following the
controversy over zero dark thirty but
when it comes to torture
I trust the lady who spent three years
married to James Cameron Billboard Music
Award goes to Justin Timberlake I want
to thank everybody on earth everybody on
earth except except Donald sterling I
don't
[Applause]
he's the star of Iron Man two girls and
a guy Wonder Boys sorry these porn films
what Kiss Kiss Bang Bang Bowfinger
really yeah the Academy come on he has
done all those films but many of you in
this room probably know him best from
such facilities as the Betty Ford Clinic
and Los Angeles County Jail please
welcome Robert Downey jr. this backstage
de lattre celebrities back there I was
talking to Jerry Jones the other cat was
on her and he's disappointed obviously
yeah
he's a good guy though and he's he's
talking about rebuilding the team you
know and he told me he says we have to
get back to what made us a championship
team strippers and crack Woody Allen is
the recipient of this year's Cecil B
deMille Award just a few years after
Martin Scorsese wanted I assumed the
award is for tiniest man with the
biggest glasses once upon a time in
Hollywood nearly three hours long
Leonardo DiCaprio attended the premiere
and by the end his date was too old for
him a popular thing to say but I want to
say thank you to president from I mean
remember last year when it seemed like
the Oscars were racist and now back to
this [ __ ] that had a lot to say about
me to other day in the press
Miley looks good
[Applause]
we're all in this industry we all do
interviews and we all know how they
manipulate [ __ ] Nicky
congratu-fucking-lations you probably
know me as the creator of the office no
you don't do you
you think Steve Carell do oh he's
brilliant isn't he Steve Carell these
amazing as the bumbling office manager
where does he get his ideas from that's
right
Matt Damon is here for behind the
candelabra on any other night in any
other room you would be a big deal but
tonight and don't take this the wrong
way you're basically a garbage person
you could be a little a little child a
little Asian child with no possessions
and no money but you get a you see a
picture of Angelina Jolie and you think
mummy Jeff Bezos is the founder and CEO
and I want to say congratulations to
Jeff you know I also want you know Jeffy
if you win tonight you could expect your
Oscar to arrive in two to five business
days
Joaquin Phoenix is nominated for
inherent vice but obviously he isn't
here tonight because he has said
publicly that award shows our quote
total and utter bull oh hey Joaquin
our first presenter is beautiful
talented and Jewish apparently Mel
Gibson told me that he's obsessed
please welcome Scarlett Johansson let's
get on with it before NBC replaced me
with Jay Leno on a serious note just
looking at all the faces here reminds me
of some of the great work that's been
done this year by cosmetic surgeons one
stereotype I hate is that all Irishmen
are just drunk
sweary hellraisers please welcome Colin
Farrell the the Catholic Church are
furious about the film as it exposes the
fact that 5% of all their priests have
repeatedly molested children and been
allowed to continue to work without
punishment
Roman Polanski called it the best date
movie ever